this is downtown Los Angeles and I'm
going to blow it up with a nuclear bomb
okay not actually that would be too
expensive but I am going to use visual
effects to show you what that would look
like you
you were familiar with nuclear weapons I
mean they're depicted in movies all the
time however they never do a good job of
showing what actually happens during a
nuclear explosion I mean this movie
would have you believe that you could
survive a nuke just by getting in your
fridge that's not how the force works
even when we look at real test footage
it's still difficult to truly understand
the power that's on display they're
always in these desolate remote
locations with nothing nearby to
visually compare their size to at least
this test in the ocean had battleships
for scale on their own it's just really
hard to grasp the true magnitude of
these explosions take a look at this
shot if you saw the movie Oppenheimer
then you're already familiar with the
first test of a nuclear bomb Trinity
sure it seems powerful but it's not
until I put the 900 foot tall Eiffel
Tower next to it that you can begin to
grasp its true scale now imagine instead
of blowing up this bomb in the desert it
actually blew up in downtown Los Angeles
well you don't have to imagine this five
four three
two one
oh trust we'll come back to this in a
moment so stay tuned I just wanted to
give you some context first because
let's be honest this is kind of weird
it's hard for me to make a video in my
upbeat tone about weapons of mass
destruction so I'm going to focus on the
science behind the explosion itself
because that is truly mind-blowing
explosions are actually pretty simple
they're just huge releases of energy
over a short amount of time now the vast
majority of explosions are the result of
chemical reactions such as the gunpowder
that fires bullets or military
explosives that use TNT
okay quick clarification about TNT and
dynamite because a lot of people seem to
think that they're the same thing but
they're not Dynamite is solidified
nitroglycerin which is very unstable and
dangerous
on the other hand TNT or try Nitro
toluene is so safe and shock resistant
that it took 30 years for people to even
figure out that it could explode people
used to use it to like dye their clothes
yellow I'm not kidding these days
however TNT is one of the most commonly
used explosive chemicals in the world
used for everything from geological
surveys to hand grenades did you know
that hand grenades just have TNT inside
of them because I didn't I mean I do now
82. nuclear bombs however just hit
different in movies you can always tell
it's a nuke because there's a mushroom
cloud it's a very distinctive shape
however this shape isn't actually
exclusive to nukes mushroom clouds occur
from any sufficiently large explosion
it's just how thermals work in the air
in fact the first documented example of
a mushroom cloud is from the 1700s so
how do nukes hit different instead of a
chemical reaction it is a nuclear
reaction and thanks to this dude who had
special relatives we have the equation E
equals MC squared which basically just
means that energy is the same thing as
mass stuff can be converted into pure
energy and pure energy can be converted
back into stuff
so in a nuclear explosion stuff like
uranium ascends Beyond its
three-dimensional form to become pure
energy and it is a lot a lot of energy
yeah so notice that little c squared
from the equation that stands for the
speed of light times the speed of light
so energy is actually equal to the mass
of something times 90 quadrillion you
don't need a lot of Mass to equal a lot
of it
for example a single drop of water has a
mass of .05 grams it's a tiny minuscule
amount of water but even converting just
this much mass into energy would yield
an explosion as large as the one we saw
in Beirut in 2020.
foreign
accident was one of the most powerful
non-nuclear blasts in history it had
enough concussive force to shake the
entire country of Lebanon and yet it was
still only a 20th the size of the
Trinity test while the Beirut explosion
was caused by a warehouse full of
ammonium nitrates Trinity was fueled by
a core of plutonium just the size of a
bowling ball nukes released so much
energy that a new unit of measurement
had to be formed two months before
Oppenheimer detonated the gadget they
blew up 100 tons of TNT or 0.1 kilotons
this explosion was literally Humanity
making a big Mark in the earth and going
yep that's my measuring stick now
and this is how physicists were able to
figure out that the size of the Trinity
explosion was the equivalent of 21
000 tons of TNT or 21 kilotons but
here's something crazy in 2021 they
actually reanalyzed the data and
determined that the actual yield of this
explosion was 25 kilotons so uh yeah as
if that distinction even matters when
you're blowing up a city
speaking of which five four three
now
in the first one millionth of a second
after nuclear detonation the heat is
already so extreme that a ball of plasma
forms it's a fireball so hot it reduces
everything inside it to subatomic
particles the core of our star is 15
million degrees Celsius making it the
hottest point in the entire solar system
but for a brief moment in time it
becomes the second hottest point because
the core of a nuclear Fireball can reach
100 million degrees to put that in
perspective that's 20 000 times hotter
than the vaporization point of diamond
one of the most resilient materials in
the entire universe so it doesn't matter
if you're in a fridge or a bunker or a
bunker made of diamond if you're inside
of this Fireball you will get deleted
from existence all this heat radiates
outward at the speed of light instantly
scorching anything unfortunate enough to
be within view this real test footage
shows the paint getting vaporized at the
moment of detonation it's quite
literally a laser engraver but like
everywhere anything combustible
immediately ignites on fire including
everything within a mile of this
explosion all the people within a mile
and a half would receive third degree
burns it's a burn so bad you don't even
feel it and looking at this test footage
what I find fascinating is that it's not
actually windy what we're seeing is the
heat of the nuke pushing the smoke away
like it's the solar wind or something
it's just that intense the real wind and
the most Devastation is still to come
the Shockwave is a sphere of high
pressure air that expands outward faster
than the speed of sound in fact this
shock wave is so powerful it levels up
into something even deadlier when it
hits the ground it reflects back up to
recombine with itself forming what's
called a mock stem it gives the
Shockwave a Razor's Edge Shaving the
city down to Rubble it's been a few
seconds at this point but the explosion
is still happening the Shockwave leaves
behind a pressure vacuum which sucks all
the air back in with hurricane force
winds it's not as strong as the initial
shock wave but this is more Insidious as
the air rushes back into the city it
delivers fresh oxygen to all of the
all the fire the rushing air feeds the
Flames which create fire tornadoes that
swell to hundreds of feet high this
terrifying reality is called a firestorm
and is exactly what happened to
Hiroshima it was a city made almost
entirely of wood
thank you
yeah that got kind of real
I wanted to show you a hypothetical
explosion so that we could separate the
physics of nukes from the lives they've
taken but I don't think I can do that
separating the science from the deaths
it's impossible nukes are not fun
they're weapons of war and the
devastation they've caused isn't
something we should ever ignore or ever
forget especially because this one
was a small nuke World War II may have
ended but the cold war had just begun it
was an arms race between America and
Russia to build bigger and bigger bombs
such as the b-83 it's the most powerful
nuke in America's Arsenal right now and
yet physically it's not that big it's 12
feet long in fact the Warhead itself is
just right up here at the front for
something so small
how powerful could it be 1 200 kilotons
yeah this is a Megaton bomb I'm using a
tool called nuke Maps if you just Google
search nuke Maps you'll find this just
plug in the Warhead yield of your choice
whether or not it's detonating on the
surface or if it's an air burst then you
just hit detonate
this is the fireball this is the
strongest part of the shock wave and
this signifies where everyone gets third
degree burns this is what the Trinity
explosion would look like in downtown
L.A but if I put in the b83 of 1200
kilotons that detonation would look like
this it's like almost two miles wide
just the fireball now the b83 is just
the most powerful nuke that we currently
have in our Arsenal we've tested many
more powerful nukes for instance the
Russians tested the Tsar Bomba which was
a 50 Megaton bomb this would literally
destroy the entirety of Los Angeles
just turned on the casualties
estimated casualties are about 3 million
people
instantly
I think there's a good reason why people
don't normally think about this stuff
going back to the b83 yes this is
smaller but we built
650. there are 650 of these things just
out there in the world somewhere that is
enough to Scorch every single square
inch of California
are you scared yet
I am we don't need 650 of these bombs I
mean whether or not we need them at all
is a separate conversation but 650 I
think we can all agree that is too many
mutually assured destruction is still
assured destruction but thankfully there
is hope both the US and Russia have
reduced their nuclear stockpile by 50
000 Warheads since the height of the
Cold War think about that for a moment
two nations with a history of animosity
and distrust wable has set aside Their
Fear of each other and put most of their
weapons down when I see that I don't see
a species trying to destroy themselves I
see a species with a reason to save
themselves and that gives me hope we
need more of that for the safety of us
all
but thanks for watching
if you thought the explosions in this
video were cool well I've got something
special for you I've included a download
link to a preset so that you can
simulate your own nukes using a
real-time Sim program called Ember gen
it simulates smoke and fire like
lightning fast and lastly what would
happen to the Earth at the universal
logo was real well I made a whole video
about it right here going into detail
about exactly what would happen spoilers
The world would end but how well you
gotta watch the video to find out it's
right here click it